puede que no sea un personaje muy
conocido y desde luego no dirige un gran
estado sino más bien un país
relativamente pequeño y formalmente ni
siquiera es el líder máximo del país
tiene embargo amigos a pesar de ello el
pasado día 2 de junio de 2019 el new
york times' publicó un reportaje en el
que consideraba a mohamed bin zayed como
el líder político árabe más poderoso del
mundo incluso por encima del nuevo líder
de facto de arabia saudita mohamed bin
salman del que ya os hemos hablado en
visual político en alguna que otra
ocasión os dejo vídeos en la descripción
el caso es que tras el reportaje
publicado en el 'new york times' nos
hicimos algunas preguntas quienes
realmente mohamed bin zayed cuáles son
las claves de su poder es realmente el
líder político árabe más poderoso del
mundo atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
mohamed bin zayed es el príncipe
heredero de abu dhabi el emirato más
rico y poderoso de los emiratos árabes
unidos-
[Música]
también es el comandante supremo adjunto
de las fuerzas armadas de emiratos y el
presidente del consejo ejecutivo de abu
dhabi es decir el presidente del
gobierno de abu dabi casi nada
y es que amigos sus capacidades
políticas junto a la mala salud de su
hermano mayor el jeque khalifa min
le han convertido en el líder de facto
de abu dhabi y por extensión de todos
los emiratos árabes unidos- emiratos
árabes unidos- es un pequeño país con un
tamaño parecido al de panamá o carolina
del sur situado en el golfo pérsico es
un país que está formado a su vez por
siete emiratos diferentes de los que con
mucha diferencia los dos más conocidos
son abu dhabi y dubai de hecho a pesar
de ser siete los emiratos que forman el
país lo cierto es que a nivel político
abu dabi es con mucha diferencia el
emirato más importante porque lo vamos a
ver en este vídeo pero os adelantamos ya
un motivo de mucho peso
abu dabi concentra más del 90 por ciento
de todas las reservas de petróleo de
emiratos árabes
pero de todo esto lo haremos más tarde
de momento regresemos a mohamed bin
taller de ruedas
lo que sé es que a quién ya ayudar
francesc antich
[Música]
este personaje amigos nació en el año
1961 y fue el tercer hijo del jeque
zayed bin sultan y el primer presidente
de los emiratos árabes unidos desde muy
joven enfocó su carrera hacia el
ejército donde llegó a convertirse en
piloto de las fuerzas aéreas y es
precisamente ahí donde arrancó su
carrera política veréis en 1991 justo
después de la invasión de kuwait por
parte de irak de sadam husein el
entonces comandante de las fuerzas
aéreas emiratíes aterrizó en washington
con una misión comprar todos los equipos
militares que fueran posibles misiles
hellfire y helicópteros apache aviones
f-16 querían el paquete completo
[Música]
desde ese preciso momento nuestro
protagonista se convirtió en uno de los
aliados más estrechos de washington no
sólo los países árabes sino incluso en
todo el planeta
[Música]
hablamos de un líder político que con el
paso de los años se ha convertido en uno
de los iconos del reformismo y la
apertura en el mundo árabe bajo su
gestión
abu dabi ha seguido los pasos
aperturistas tanto en materia económica
como civil de dubai e incluso en algunas
cuestiones ha ido más allá tal vez la
mejor prueba de ello sea la visita del
propio papá francisco al mira tos de la
que ya os hablamos hace poco tiempo aquí
en visual político sin embargo al mismo
tiempo que ha liderado un programa de
reformas que ha convertido a emiratos
tal vez en el país más aperturista y
próspero del mundo árabe también
defiende a capa y espada una idea que
puede resultarnos al menos controvertida
que hoy por hoy el mundo árabe no está
preparado para la democracia
si lo habéis escuchado bien según bin
zayed el aperturismo en el mundo árabe
es solo puede ser liderado por regímenes
autoritarios promover democracias no
haría más que alimentar a grupos
fundamentalistas que terminarían ganando
las elecciones es una idea que defiende
activamente y que ha marcado
profundamente la agenda exterior de
emiratos en los últimos años pero amigos
dicho esto creo que ahora sí tenemos que
empezar a responder a la pregunta clave
de este vídeo donde recala y cuánto
poder tiene realmente este personaje
veamos cuáles son las tres principales
claves los cimientos de su poder atentos
[Música]
el poder de la cartera
vale no creo que os resulta extraña
ninguno si os digo que el dinero siempre
ha sido uno de los elementos de poder
más importantes que han existido pues
bien si por algo han sido famosos los
países árabes ha sido por derrochar
cantidades indecentes de dinero en todo
tipo de cosas caprichos o proyectos que
luego no iban a ninguna parte verdad
pues amigos en este caso además de
gastar mucho dinero en todo tipo de
proyectos públicos lo que también han
hecho los emiratos ha sido ahorrar e
invertir buena parte de su dinero por
todo el planeta
[Música]
pero aquí la pregunta es exactamente
cuánto dinero tienen ahorrado los
emiratos y abu dhabi en sus fondos
soberanos de cuánto diantres estamos
hablando para los que no lo sepáis un
fondo soberano es un fondo de inversión
que un gobierno crea para invertir sus
ahorros en activos que tienen la misión
de generar rentabilidad vamos como un
fondo de inversión para cualquier
ahorrador
el caso es que según las últimas
estimaciones los fondos soberanos de
emiratos árabes unidos- acumulan
inversiones por valor de más de 13
billones de dólares
de esta cantidad algo más de 900 mil
millones se concentran en los dos
principales fondos soberanos de abu
dhabi la autoridad de inversiones de abu
dhabi que controla casi 700 mil millones
y que es el tercer mayor fondo soberano
de todo el planeta y el fondo mubadala
con algo más de 200 mil millones de
dólares norteamericanos
hablamos de una fortuna descomunal más
de 900 mil millones ahorrados por el
emirato de abu dhabi e invertidos por
todo el mundo en acciones deuda
edificios autopistas puertos aeropuertos
bancos hospitales hoteles fábricas minas
e incluso heladerías de todo y eso es
precisamente lo que explica noticias
como estas abu dabi paga 495 millones a
abertis por el 20 por ciento de su
filial chilena la autoridad de inversión
de abu dhabi invertirá 50 mil millones
en la india
el fondo de abu dhabi uno de los fondos
soberanos más grandes del mundo
destinará 50 mil millones a la india
especialmente a infraestructura y
capacidad de procesamiento de alimentos
[Música]
y ojo porque el poder no sólo está en
tener la cartera llena sino en controlar
activos y empresas de todo tipo por todo
el planeta y también en ser un dinero
muy pero que muy codiciado por la
mayoría de los gobiernos y él no quiere
unos cuantos miles de millones de
inversión en su país eso sí que es
diplomacia
[Música]
en cualquier caso hay un detalle que no
nos podemos saltar y un consejo agarraos
a una silla veréis el emirato de abu
dhabi tiene una población de apenas 27
millones de personas de las cuales poco
más de medio millón tienen la
nacionalidad emiratí es decir los
ahorros del emirato de abu dhabi tan
solo en sus dos principales fondos
soberanos ascienden a más de 340 mil
dólares por cada habitante y a más de
1,6 millones de dólares por cada
ciudadano con la nacionalidad emiratí 16
millones de dólares llevan ahorrando
desde el año 1976 y ojo porque a pesar
de estar sentados sobre semejante
cantidad de dinero se toma muy pero que
muy en serio que el gobierno no tenga
déficit público desde luego mucho más en
serio que las autoridades argentinas
abu dabi registrará un superávit en 2019
gracias a los esfuerzos de consolidación
presupuestaria pero amigos esta no es la
única clave del poder de mohamed bin
zayed
[Música]
el poder de la fuerza
tal vez es la cara menos conocida de los
emiratos pero durante los últimos años
este pequeño país se ha ganado el apodo
de la pequeña esparta y es que veréis el
ejército de emiratos es muy pequeñito si
tiene poco más de 60.000 soldados pero
amigos durante las últimas dos décadas
bajo la dirección de mohamed bin zayed y
un montón de expertos entre los que por
cierto se encuentra el mismísimo ex
secretario de defensa de los eeuu james
mattis este ejército se ha
reestructurado con una idea ser un
ejército pequeño pero muy bien equipado
ágil y bien entrenado
[Música]
para ello cada año el presupuesto
militar de mirat o superan los 20 mil
millones de dólares lo que les ha
permitido comprar todo tipo de equipos
extranjeros 70 f-16 actualizados con la
última tecnología otros 70 miras 30
apaches 19 chinooks más de 400 tanques
leclerc 76 scorpions miles de vehículos
blindados de todo tipo decenas de drones
el sistema antimisiles patriot
[Música]
hasta se han comprado la joya de la
corona el sistema antimisiles está uno
de los sistemas más modernos de los eeuu
el mismo que la potencia norteamericana
desplegó en corea del sur provocando un
enorme enfrentamiento con china
[Música]
y esto es sólo el comienzo ahora por
ejemplo están detrás del f-35
de hecho emiratos es después de arabia
saudi el segundo mayor comprador de
tecnología y equipos militares de los
eeuu pero vale es verdad si por algo han
sido conocidos tradicionalmente los
ejércitos árabes ha sido por gastarse un
montón de dinero en equipos que a la
hora de la verdad pues no eran capaces
de sacar provecho por eso otra prioridad
de mohamed 2010 ha sido lograr que el
ejercito emiratí esté bien entrenado y
que creéis que ha hecho para conseguirlo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pues amigos además de pagar todo tipo de
entrenamientos y cursos de formación en
el extranjero el ejercito emiratí se ha
hinchado a entrar en combate durante los
últimos años especialmente de la mano de
los mismísimos eeuu tal cual como lo
escucháis
desde el año 2003 emiratos ha desplegado
tropas de élite en afganistán ha enviado
tropas a somalia para combatir la
piratería y tras eeuu ha sido el país
que más misiones aéreas han llevado a
cabo contra el estado islámico siempre
mano a mano con eeuu y no sólo eso
recientemente también han intervenido
por su propia cuenta en libia en el
norte del sinaí en egipto y de forma
masiva en yemen
por supuesto también han contratado a un
montón de expertos de todo el mundo de
tal forma que algunas unidades están
incluso bajo mando de oficiales
extranjeros es decir han fichado a sus
propios oficiales es el caso por ejemplo
del general tú mahan un ex teniente
coronel del ejército de los eeuu que hoy
está al mando de la división de
helicópteros emiratí o del australiano
mick mars que dirige la guardia
presidencial
el resultado es que hoy el ejército
emiratí es considerado uno de los
ejércitos no sólo mejor equipados sino
también mejor entrenados de toda la
región vamos tan sólo por detrás de
israel país al que por cierto están
comprando tecnología y eso no es todo
además para ganar autonomía las
autoridades emiratíes han restablecido
el servicio militar obligatorio que han
puesto mucho pero que muchísimo dinero
sobre la mesa para desarrollar todo una
industria armamentística nacional una
industria militar propia eso sí siempre
de la mano de las grandes
multinacionales y tecnología que una
cosa ser autónomo y otra pues bueno
gracias
[Música]
y lo cierto es que lo están consiguiendo
actualmente hay casi 200 empresas de
defensa emiratí es fabricando todo tipo
de equipos blindados misiles guiados
drones aviones ligeros todo fabricado en
emiratos ahora incluso están tratando de
desarrollar su propio bombardero de
hélices para operar a baja altitud en
misiones de contrainsurgencia
pero amigos no tengáis prisa porque aún
hay más emiratos ha abierto bases
militares en lugares como yemen eritrea
y somaliland lo que no tiene precedentes
y se ha preparado para operar junto a
ejércitos mercenarios mercenarios de
élite liderados por erik prince el
fundador y propietario de la compañía
black water que complementan las
capacidades de su propio ejército
emiratos envía secretamente mercenarios
colombianos a la guerra de yemen en fin
ya lo veis este es el cambio que se ha
producido en el ejército emiratí y que
les ha valido el calificativo de pequeña
esparta todo de la mano de nuestro
protagonista pero esta no es su última
bala
[Música]
geoestrategia al poder con unas reservas
probadas de más de 97 mil millones de
barriles
emiratos tiene bajo su subsuelo las
séptimas mayores reservas de petróleo
convencionales del planeta
actualmente están produciendo unos 3
millones de barriles cada día y esperan
alcanzar los 4 millones en 2020 y los 5
millones para el año 2030 eso es mucho
muchísimo petróleo así que con todo ese
petróleo y con todo el dinero que hemos
visto mohamed bin zayed se ha lanzado a
toda una carrera diplomática a lo largo
y ancho de todo el planeta que ha
multiplicado en los últimos años la
influencia internacional de este pequeño
país
en indonesia etiopía y por supuesto eeuu
sus relaciones con la administración
trump son formidables y lo cierto es que
con semejantes activos bajo el brazo no
hay puerta que se le resista nuestro
protagonista y si a todo esto le sumamos
que emiratos se ha convertido durante
las últimas dos décadas en un
importantísimo centro financiero
comercial logístico e incluso turístico
y que de facto al frente de todo está
este hombre mohamed bin zayed no parece
descabellado pensar que hoy por hoy sea
el líder político árabe más poderoso del
mundo
desde luego tal y como habéis visto
razones para alcanzar este calificativo
no faltan esos y que sea el árabe más
poderoso no implica que todo le salga
bien ni muchísimo menos
el bloqueo a qatar ha sido un rotundo
fracaso pero de eso ya os hablamos en
este vídeo y ahora ahora una cosa muy
importante si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante
no olvides darle a like y por supuesto
suscribirte al isr polític si aún no lo
has hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]